Nice!
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuhören.
Die
Wenn ich eine weile hier einfach nur enter gedrückt haben und dann los gelassen habe es ist jetzt ist es instant hat es noch
Vier fünf sekunden nachgeleckt da war irgendwo was war irgendwo was verkehrt ich zeige euch jetzt mal woran das woran das gelegen hat
Ist das
Gleich
Irgendwie sowas oder nehmen wir mal das default die default colors ist auch egal
Guckt mal leute es leckt wieder seht ihr
So ich sage euch wenn ich den knopf los lasse ich sage euch wenn ich den knopf los lasse jetzt
Und jetzt ist erst fertig habt ihr es gesehen wie es leckt
Und das liegt daran
Sobald ich ein color scheme. Guck jetzt ist schnell
Achtung ich lasse jetzt
instant also die haben in den back sobald ein color ein color scheme gesetzt ist
Dann leckt das ich habe die vermutung
Dass die das hinter der haube nicht cashen sondern jedes mal neu von der platte einlesen bei jedem mal enter drücken oder irgendwie sowas anders
Kann ich mir das nicht erklären ich verstehe es zumindest nicht?
zumindest color scheme ist langsam wir können mal kurz
Bei dem bei dem bei dem kerl auf github gucken ob das ob das dazu vielleicht schon was gibt
Kann ich die playlist mal please entscheiden ob sie laut
So laut oder leise sein will
Wir gucken mal kurz in den in den issues ob da irgendetwas drin all das 251
Na gut das ist halt ein eintrag in der config
Leggy tapp repainting
Leck
Soll ich mal da leck suchen
leck issues leck weister leck's behind color
leck leck high cpu usage
leck
leck ne
Oh performance usage
Es liegt übrigens auf jeden fall nicht an den farben
Ja ok keine ahnung findet man nichts zu hätte gedacht vielleicht das in kombination leck
Also wie gesagt wenn color scheme gesetzt ist wir sortieren das ganze mal noch nach neuesten
Leggy
Ich verbiere bist du auf dem main branch
Das ist eine gute frage ne ich bin auf dem letzten release branch
Hier guck mal ich bin auf dem letzten release brand ich bin auf november 2022 das ist von gestern ach guck mal da
Leggy tapp repainting mit mecki ja das das habe ich schon aber doch was anderes oder
Das ist das doch ist das habe ich eben ja auch gerade gefunden aber das scheint mir also das ist das issue hier
Wir können es ausprobieren ob es auf dem main gefixt ist pass mal auf guck wir gucken mal
Aber das scheint mir doch was anderes zu sein wayland
bsp ok das ist x es ist x hier pico müssen wir auch noch machen dass wir ein bisschen
Bisschen transparent haben
Ach guck mal da hat ein video ok zeige uns mal zeige uns mal das geleckte
Ach guck mal man kann sogar icons in den tabs haben das ist pogu
Das brauche ich icons in tabs
Sau
Will er den will er den autor flamen oder ist das ab? Ne das ist keine absicht. Sau 2 3 4
Scheint ich glaube das ist was anderes ich glaube das ist was anderes
Zumindest ich habe festgestellt am color scheme liegt es nicht also an den farben selbst liegt es nicht
Aber ich glaube das ist was anderes ich glaube das ist was anderes
Ich habe festgestellt am color scheme liegt es nicht also an den farben selbst liegt es nicht weil guckt jetzt sich schnell
Ja bin ich korrekt
So
E3 config editieren hier
Und sobald ich in color scheme rein mache laggy seht ihr es man sieht ja auch schon beim enter drücken wie sehr das hinterher legt
Und jetzt zack und kaum mache ich das raus
Kaum mache ich das raus ist wieder super fast
Man sieht es ja auch schon beim enter drücken also es könnte es könnte vielleicht wirklich der gleiche der gleiche bug sein
Wir können mal wir können mal tatsächlich
Wir können mal tatsächlich das den den neuesten master installieren
Ich finde sehr nice dass der verschiedene icons hier oben hat und sowas
Ich muss mir unbedingt die config abgucken von manchen leuten da kann man wirklich cooles zeug machen gibt glaube kein neidli bild doch gibt es
Es sah zumindest so aus. This should be fixed in main. Doch hier guck da
Also man muss es selbst kompilieren am ende das wäre das wird ja nicht so schwierig sein also nehmen wir mal das
Ach jetzt muss man doch rust installieren ah ok meinetwegen
Installieren ah ok meinetwegen
Es installieren wir mal die neueste ja ja dann installieren wir mal die neueste version
Das ist von main branche die die git repos sind immer von main branche also meistens zu 99 prozent ist das einfach das neueste das neueste
Also meistens zu 99 prozent ist das einfach das neueste das neueste der neueste master stand der da genommen wird
Der da genommen wird
Die rust installation in play singly fast aber bilden von rustprogramm ist nicht unbedingt play singly fast
Probieren wir das mal aus lassen wir installieren noch mal die neueste version von dem terminal und gucken ob es immer noch laggy ist
Lag af das problem ist also es ist gar kein großartiges problem
Weil ich will eh das farbschema anpassen also kann ich eh kein preset nehmen ich will eh ein paar sachen von hand anpassen also insofern
Ist nicht wirklich schlimm dass es das ist
So nicht funktioniert
Alter free type was zum teufel lädt er sich da alles runter will er jetzt auch noch free type ok ok wir sehen uns in zwei stunden wieder
Naja gut ganz so schlimm ist nicht weil ich meine ich habe halt einfach mal acht kerne da drin das sollte ganz gut für es sollte ganz gut flutschen
Ach was gibt schön in der sonntag abend 18.50 erst mal eine runde play singly fast written in rust zu kompilieren
Oh jetzt jetzt hat er aber den turbo eingelegt hier
sources ready building
Acht kerne alter leck das stream
Das ding haut aber mal richtig rein alter
Hey, das ding lastet ja fast so viel aus wie prime 95 alter das sind 13.900 k und ist erst mal acht course voll mit kompilieren easy
Es ist aber halt play singly fast written in rust da gibt es nix
Nee, die haben keine daily builds so wie es aussieht die haben releases tags könnte man halt ko-
Nö, die scheinen keine daily builds oder sowas zu haben
Vielleicht vielleicht auf flat pack aber ganz ehrlich who cares ach doch nightly app image
Könnte man auch machen ok das ist ja auch ein
verkehrt wir könnten auch ein nightly build wir könnten auch ein nightly bild nehmen egal wir machen selbst ein bild
Aber ist auch fast schon fertig kompiliert
Daku dankeschön für den zapp
Ich habe es übrigens gar gar überhaupt kein zapp
Ich habe es übrigens gar gar gar überhaupt kein zapp
Er kompiliert echtes halbe internet
Hyper gachi wird auch kompiliert
ist das extra dass diese kunden aktuell ich glaube der rechner leckt gerade ein bisschen
weil er ausgelastet ist also die urzeit könnte auch sein das ist das ist die fault die default
i3 status bar die ist richtig minimalistisch die kommt auch noch weg erstens sieht die hässlich
erst fack aus unterstützt glaube ich keine transparenz und naja die anzeige ist auch
gewöhnungsbedürftig ihr habt recht so passt schon wie wir machen nicht i3 status was wir
probieren bambelbima aus immer mal ein bisschen paar neue sachen testen viel slack man
wie das einfach hättet ihr gedacht dass das beim kompilieren wirklich einfach jetzt die
komplette cpu auslastet von für das terminus hätte ich nicht gedacht mein rast ist ja bekannt
dafür dass das irgendwie 30 milliarden abhängigkeiten kompilieren pass auf jetzt
jetzt ein fehler passt auf jetzt ein fehler jetzt ein compiler fehler beim letzten beim letzten
bildstep das wird mich nicht wundern kannst du nehmen i3 noch eine andere der i3 ist ja nur
der window manager du kannst du kannst Ubuntu nehmen in der vm und i3 installieren auch kein
problem oder du nimmst xfce oder mint mint mit mate finde ich auch ganz nice in der in der vm
wenn man was fertiges haben will remove western yes yes so zwar und das terminale auf und war
das termin ok jetzt haben wir das aber die neueste version hatte so was wie minus minus version
vielleicht 2023 01 21 18 uhr 24 29 ja alles ist es überhaupt 18 ist es überhaupt 18 uhr 24 ich
meine an der du zuletzt committed vor 16 stunden nicht so ganz doch nee ach was auch immer also das
hier hinten ist auf jeden fall der kommet hasch was das hier was das hier sein soll weiß ich gar
nicht das ist auf jeden fall nicht die patch version auch nicht kommet seit letztem tag weil
kommet seit letztem tag wäre ein bisschen viele na gut also schauen wir mal ob der fehler jetzt
behoben ist ob es jetzt noch blazing liefer ist weil written in rust ist es ja eh schon das
kann er leute das ist eigentlich es geht eigentlich nicht eigentlich kann es nicht langsam sein easy
ist gefixt ist gefixt im neuesten master ist gefixt funst es funst leute im neuesten master ist es ok
das wird wir wissen wir kommen hier das trotzdem wieder aus weil ich will ja mein eigenes farbschema haben
schau mal was sie geändert haben wahrscheinlich jede menge seit ich meine der letzte tag war im
november also ich würde jetzt ungern hier durch bis november und durchgucken also ich vermute mal
die haben irgendwas geändert wie das parsing ich habe was mit parsing sehen okay irgendwas
oder color irgendwas mit color ach keine ahnung das gucken wir jetzt nicht zumindest das ist
gefixt das ist jetzt blazing lieferst wieder alles es ist weiter ja ich habe aber erst angefangen
vor zehn minuten oder so gut also jetzt haben wir einen terminal schnell wobei ich ganz ehrlich
sagen muss leute ich werde das wieder ich werde das wir haben wir haben es zwar wir haben es zwar
selbst komplett ich werde das aber wieder an installen und das normale installieren weil ich
keinen bock habe auf jedes mal gett bild sobald es ein update gibt also wir nehmen jetzt lieber
das normale das ist auch schnell genug was ist der plan wir richten heute die ledungs vm weiter ein
und probieren weiter neue sachen aus also jetzt ist mein terminal wieder schön schnell jetzt passt
mal auf ich habe mir was überlegt wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt absolut six hat da hat mich
schon morgen der chat auf die idee gebracht also ich meine es muss ja six hat sein wenn der chat
mich auf die idee gebracht hat weil hat der chat schon jemals irgendwas auch nur im ansatz
vorgeschlagen was nicht absolut next level high IQ ist kann mich nicht erinnern kommt eigentlich
nicht vor und so neidli neidli bild so und zwar es gibt doch immer das problem dass wenn man caps
drückt und gehe ich jetzt eigentlich rausholen wenn man caps lock drückt aus versehen dann
schreibt man groß und niemand braucht die caps lock tast so und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe was
doch richtig praktisch wäre wenn man caps lock einfach als copy verwenden können als copy knopf
und das muss soweit ich das gesehen habe in der terminal konfig relativ easy sein
also man kann zum beispiel nämlich jemand nach caps sucht caps caps lock dann findet man zum
beispiel so was hier und bla bla bla bla wo caps lock disabled ist zum beispiel wenn man das hier
setzt caps und escape habe ich schon probiert mag ich nicht habe ich schon vor einer ganzen weile
mal ausprobiert das mag ich nicht so und jetzt kann man zum beispiel sagen
moment copy copy 2 brauche ich
copy 2 genau das hier brauche ich jetzt keys und jetzt müsste ich wenn das wenn das funktioniert
in meinem terminal einstellen können wir mal hier hier rein das sind wir stehen geblieben
so also das habe ich übrigens gestern noch eingefügt kann ich euch auch noch zeigen
gestern auch nach dem stream hier unten diese die die mappings so jetzt müsste ich hier eintragen
key und wie war das was man eintragen muss was mit void weil man weiß nicht warum aber genau so
und jetzt kann ich einstellen key void symbol mods machen wir weg copy to clipboard so wenn
das jetzt funktioniert also caps lock ist jetzt disabled aber ich kann jetzt mit caps lock copy
machen also ich klicke jetzt mal an caps und ein funst leute ich habe jetzt caps lock als
steuerung c ersatz was super praktisch ist im terminal ich muss mal gucken ob ich mich
daran gewöhne aber der chat hat heute morgen eine wirklich gute idee gehabt weil im terminal
kannst du kein control c drücken und schrift control c finde ich nervig also ich werde ich
werde zwei sachen ich werde zwei sachen probieren einmal copy auf copy auf caps lock mal gucken ob
das sinnvoll ist zsr ist schon ist aber nicht eingerichtet also copy auf caps lock und dann
brauche ich noch maus bindings fürs terminal maus bindings und da habe ich schon was vorbereitet
oder system weit caps zu copy key machen das wiederum will ich nicht das ist dann wirklich
was terminal was terminal eigen ist jetzt das finde ich schon ganz gut im restlichen system
soll es wahrscheinlich eher gar nichts machen weil da kann man nämlich control c drücken
ich weiß so nicht genau also ich wusste ich habe den ich das tut mir wirklich ein bisschen
leid ich habe den die ersten 15 minuten wo ich dieses terminal ausprobiert habe habe ich
ein bisschen schlecht geredet weil es halt wirklich scheiß default settings hat aber
mittlerweile muss ich sagen es ist das beste terminal was ich die letzten jahre über so
ausprobiert habe du kannst alles konfigurieren was du willst und du hast dann features richtig
coole sachen zum beispiel ihr wisst ich habe sonst immer t-marks verwendet habe ich übrigens
gar nicht mein ziel guck mal ich kann jetzt einfach control 2 drücken und er splittet
ich kann control prozent drücken und er splittet ich kann arrow keys haben und durch die teil
switchen es ist ein bisschen es ist ein bisschen wie t-marks nur ohne dass man t-marks braucht
ich kann das habe ich noch nicht das habe ich glaube ich noch nicht belegt dass man
zoomen kann dass man zoomen kann dass man ein pain cross machen kann das müssen wir auch noch
sekunde wobei warte mal ich habe mir doch irgendwas raus kopiert geil das habe ich zugemacht ich
habe mir doch irgendwas raus kopiert was ich was ich hier reinhauen wollte und wo habe ich
denn wo ist mein wo ist mein text wo ist mein text feier das nee ja das da brauche ich ja
das müsste funktionieren so und jetzt kann ich split split splitten splitten horizontal
vertikal dann kann ich hier oben hingehen es laggt oh nee vodafone please es laggt überhaupt nichts
vodafone hat nichts hat nicht verkackt so und jetzt jetzt kann ich oben hingehen jetzt drücke
steuerung f und er maximiert dieses diesen tab wobei tab ist nicht das falsche wort dieses dieses
panel also er zoomt dran und der große vorteil bestimmt ist das aber keine session zu der man
disconnecten connecten kann doch das geht auch das habe ich aber noch nicht gecheckt das geht
auch das ding kann im hintergrund weiter laufen über irgendeinen socket das geht auch das kann
alles irgendwie immer wenn ich mich frage kann es das kann es das doch hätte ich nicht gedacht
deswegen sagt es ist das coolste terminal weil ich seit langem seit langem ausprobiert habe
mal ganz davon abgesehen lokal ist es jetzt ja auch nicht so wichtig dass es weiter laufen
bleibt mein startzimmer ein desktop neuen willst das was weiter läuft das kommt doch relativ selten
vor wo es wichtig ist dass ich in terminal habe was gut mit t max über ssh funktioniert nicht wie
kitty was dann wohl irgendwelche anzeige probleme hat und jetzt kann ich rein zoomen und was auch
deutlich praktischer ist was was was ich richtig was ich richtig wie sagt man so schön heute
was ich so richtig feier kannst du noch mal den namen sagen west terminal oder wetz wetz
turn wahrscheinlich sehr west turn bei dir kackt ständig der desktop ab das hatte ich noch nie
weiß nicht was du da eingestellt hast aber gut dann ist natürlich sinnvoll aber das geht damit
auch das geht damit auch so und jetzt kommt es und jetzt kommt es habe ich vergessen was ich sagen
wollte der chat hat mich abgelenkt jetzt muss mich der chat auch wieder ich weiß wieder ich
weiß wieder was was viel cooler ist was viel cooler ist man kann jetzt und das geht in t max nicht
so ohne weiteres guck mal mal angenommen ich möchte mir jetzt patz ich möchte jetzt zeilen raus kopieren
in t max kannst du nicht gescheit scrollback buffer kopieren also das geht aber ist relativ
umständlich und mit maus und tastatur geht es da nicht über mehrere seiten hinweg was du hier
machen kannst ist erstmal sagst ja gut ich will hier 20 zeilen raus kopieren gucken mal da guck mal
da also du kannst du kannst die maus ordentlich verwenden da drin das geht das kannst du in t
max vergessen und du kannst das mausrad verwenden du kannst ganz normal terminal copy pasten so wie
es sein soll und wenn du was sehen willst was du machst drückst du einfach steuerung f zooms
dran scroll mit dem mausrad dahin wo du es haben willst sagt ach ja chat ich wollte euch jetzt schon
immer mal die ganze zeit das hier kopieren und dann drücke ich die copy taste und zack zeigst
euch mal wimm aufmachen einfügen zack habe ich das im clipboard gehabt das ist unglaublich
praktisch viel besser als wenn das in einem t max läuft geht über mehrere seiten weg in dem man
scrollt während man die maus gedrückt hat ja das meine ich ja guck du kannst hier unten du kannst
hier unten du kannst sogar mit dem mausrad scrollen du kannst hier unten anfangen und du gehst dann
hoch du gehst dann hoch hoch hoch hoch und du siehst es ist immer noch alles also ich habe jetzt die
maustaste nicht mehr gedrückt und du siehst es ist immer noch alles selected und das kann ich
jetzt kopieren das kannst du in t max komplett vergessen nein das geht nicht was du in t max
machen kannst ist du kannst den scrollback buffer öffnen und im scrollback buffer per tastatur
eventuell mit mit wackeliger mausunterstützung in selection mode anmachen das ist aber nicht zu
vergleichen mit du kannst einfach reinklicken und wie in einem ordentlichen text editor scrollen mit
mausrad und und selecten das ist in t max viel viel umständlicher das ist das ist mega nice also
das gefällt mir wirklich gut also das das hat wirklich das termin hat wirklich pluspunkte
gesammelt bei mir ich bin wirklich begeistert davon wie nice wie nice das funktioniert und jetzt
müssen wir noch eine sache machen eins ist mir aufgefallen übrigens das mit dem caps lock ist
doch eine dumme idee ich will eigentlich gar nicht caps lock kopieren wir haben gerade eingefallen
eigentlich will ich der chat hatte zwar eine schlaue idee aber ich glaube ich will gar nicht
caps lock kopieren ich will ehrlich gesagt lieber rechte maustaste kopieren bei mir geht es genauso
wie es geht es mit t max das glaube ich dir nicht das glaube ich dir nicht fake news
außer wenn man die selection weg geht wenn man die mauskuid ach das ist dieser ekliche
nee nee nee nee das ist müll das ist dieser ekliche maus mode den vim auch hat wo man gar
nicht mehr richtig reinklicken kann und die sachen nicht richtig kopieren nee nee das ist
das ist müll wenn du nämlich reinklickst kopiert er dann nicht über das terminal sondern kopiert
immer in diesem selection mode dann kannst du dann zum beispiel nicht solche sachen machen wie
doppelklick für ein wort triple klick für ganze zeile und sowas und dann weiter oder oder so das
funktioniert nicht gescheit man kann sogar guck mal man kann sogar block select hier drin macht
mega nice bin ich bin ich wirklich gut gemacht so was wollte ich jetzt machen ja genau es gibt es
gibt eine sache ich möchte ich möchte eigentlich mit meiner rechten maustaste kopieren und das
funktioniert folgendermaßen das habe ich mir auch schon mal raus habe ich moment irgendwo müsste ich
es haben wo ist es ja hier das funktioniert folgendermaßen für maus ach fuck wie fügt man
überhaupt mausevents ein ich habe mir jetzt leute ich habe mir nur das hier ich habe mir nur das hier
raus kopiert das aber falsch wie macht man denn wie macht man denn jetzt maus mausevents maus
bindings ok so maus bindings so maus bein ding so und jetzt kann ich recht klicken das ist genau
das was ich haben will was habe ich vergessen ich habe kommen glaube vergessen guck mal da zeigt
dir sogar wo du syntax probleme hast so und jetzt passt mal jetzt kann ich genauso wie jetzt kann
ich es genauso benutzen wie ich haben will rechts klick also markieren mit zweimal doppel linke
linke linke maustaste markieren rechte maustaste kopieren und mittlere maustaste einfügen das ist
genau das beziehungsweise mittlere maustaste im terminal ansonsten ansonsten ist ja mittlere
maustaste wenn das noch selected hast das funktioniert ja auch du kannst ja hier machen
und dann direkt einfügen das funktioniert natürlich auch aber so kannst du jetzt zum
beispiel anklicken in buffer zum browser rüber gehen und hier reinkopieren das ist genau das wie
ich das haben will zum zum kopieren im terminal auswählen rechte maustaste hier reingehen ob sie
zwar ich aus wie hier reingehen und einfügen so das ist exzellent jetzt habe ich bloß noch
ein anderes problem wenn ich glaube das muss man eklig machen ich lade das alles hoch her
bei putti braucht man nur markieren und das ist inzwischen lag ja das sagt aber
dass das ist mist weil ich kann es dir gar nicht genau sagen ich hatte damit putti immer probleme
dass bei maustasten loslassen es kopiert war es hat ich kann es dir nicht ich kann es dir nicht
geschallt sagen warum es war auf jeden fall nicht schön also ich finde dieses so genau so
muss es sein du klickst was an und dann passiert gar nichts und erst wenn du in den copy taste
drücks kopiert aus eiskrieg und moritz dankeschön für den sub eiskrieg 32 monate massiv subscription
der ekel dankeschön eine milliarde bitts pog michael 50 milliarden ist auch am start
das ist vor allem bei workstation 17 ja ich habe geupgraded mit einem key von von
shady key verkäuferseite aber billig billig kann man auch eine scrollback persistent schaffen
ich restore immer mal eine teamark session nachdem ich meine das weiß ich nicht das
muss man tatsächlich mal gucken so ein ein problem was mir nicht gefällt gibt es aber
immer noch und dann können wir das glaube ich das letzte was wir im terminal machen
muss aber ich glaube das wird eklig zu fixen und zwar dieses das terminal unterstützt
mehrere klick rein folgen also du kannst mappen tasten druck singel klick double klick
triple klick und theoretisch geht das bis unendlich viel klick also du kannst zum beispiel du kannst
hier so eine streak angeben da kannst quasi den da kannst du den button für unterschiedliche
sachen mappen je nachdem wie oft du klickst also sprich doppelt klick macht was anderes
wie triple klick macht was anders wie vierfach klick und sowas das hat aber ein nachteil
das hat aber ein nachteil guckt mal ich zeige euch den nachteil ich kopiere jetzt das wort
und jetzt will ich das einfügen mit mittlerer maustaste guckt mal funktioniert wunderbar
einfügen mit mittlerer maustaste aber guckt mal was passiert wenn ich die maustaste schnell
drücke gar nichts einmal ich drücke jetzt die ganze zeit die maustaste einmal weil der
streak counter hoch zählt das ist keine aktion erzählt jetzt beim streak counter bei 85 oder
so und erst wenn ich kurz los lasse und wieder anfange langsam zu drücken dann das ist kein
jason das ist lua das ist lua config deswegen können wir dort auch sachen machen wie wir
jetzt machen werden passt mal auf mir fällt nichts besseres ein aber wir können guckt
mal hier kann man noch so einen streak also was ich machen will ist folgendes das habe
ich mir auch schon mal raus das habe ich mir auch schon vorbereitet moment wo ist es hier
also was wir machen wollen ist ja folgendes ne das wollen wir nicht machen wo ist es denn
ja ich habe es ich habe es nicht also im prinzip wollen wir sowas hier machen guckt wir wollen
sagen mittel der mittlere knopf soll nicht soll nicht klippert primary selection machen
sondern soll paste primary selection machen paste paste alle meine maus irgendwie proppen
das soll paste primary selection machen paste primary selection wenn ich jetzt die mittlere
maustaste drück kopierter und jetzt will ich das für mehrere streaks anlegen also für
eine ein tasten druck zwei tasten drücke teil drei tasten drücke dass ich so schnell wie
ich will die mittlere maustaste drücken kann und alles ist gut ich könnte mir vorstellen
das geht aber ich habe es nicht gefunden dass man einstellt wie lang in millisekunden quasi
die click events sind ja also das das gibt es leider nicht dann sagt er gleich hier error
geht nicht und also wenn ich hier eins reinschreibe ist kein problem dann funktioniert so was
wie bis bis streaks null können wir mal ausprobieren vielleicht geht ja streaks null vielleicht
geht ja streaks null wartet mal streaks null bringt noch nichts minus minus eins vielleicht
minus eins probier mal ausprobieren minus eins oh ne ne ne ne out of range out of range
oh wir sind ja in lua null das wird wahrscheinlich oh ne ne ne streak streak weglassen geht übrigens
auch nicht das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert das mag er auch nicht das das das mag er das
mag er auch nicht also entweder kann man irgendwie einstellen dass es für den mittleren maus
button keine streaks gibt so irgendwie button config oder sowas irgendwas mit maus oder
wir machen eine schleife was das für eine müll das ist lua wir machen eine schleife
und in die schleife lassen wir einfach hochzählen bis 99 und legen einfach dieses maus mapping
für 99 an da haben wir den vorteil dass es vielleicht kann man irgendwie once also ich
finde da jetzt nichts besseres so und deswegen wisst ihr was wir machen könnten was tatsächlich
ein vorteil ist davon dass es eine komplette programmiersprache ist wir könnten wir könnten
jetzt sowas machen ihr guckt mal licht was kann man da mit callbacks arbeiten vielleicht
keiner hast du zwischendurch eine arbeit gewechselt näher am ersten vierten als overwatch
bei release wurde meintest du dass dies auch eine suche was meintest du dass dies auch
nummer eins suche auf pornhub wäre wie kommt das wie wie das kommt weil die leute auf overwatch
porn stehen ist doch immer so jetzt kommen du willst gar nicht wissen fragt bitte nicht
woher ich das weiß du willst gar nicht wissen was in der valorant szene abgeht was bei
solchen geschichten leute kann man nicht mehr anziehen machen das ist doch normal es kommt
irgendwas raus und die leute kugeln als erstes beziehungsweise suchen erst mal auf pornhub
ob es dazu was gibt es doch logisch warum das warum das so kommt das ist wie war das
das internet ist verboten also das ist doch logisch dass sie danach suchen ist das erste
was ich erwartet hätte kannst du mitnehmen ja ja das habe ich jetzt das habe ich ja auch
vor kannst du mitnehmen kannst du kannst du eingeben auf neuen pc du kannst sogar den
gleichen key auf beiden pcs gleichzeitig verwenden habe ich mit vor immer 16 bei der
installation gemacht so weiter also das funktioniert nicht so und ich habe mir jetzt so ich habe
mir jetzt folgendes überlegt was wir machen können und zwar wir machen eine schleife also
fack wir sehen in lua lua forlup wie sieht eine schleife in lua nein nicht lua lua numerik
loops loops in lua ok excellent das will ich haben außer dass ich jetzt geblendet bin
so a gleich machen wir mal i a gleich 1 bis 100 du print ok print print will ich auf jeden
fall nicht nicht tun so und jetzt brauche ich sowas hier table nehmen wir es mal irgendwie
maus maus bindings kann man das so doppelt doppelt anlegen müssen wir gucken maus bindings
jetzt muss man sowas hier machen das weiß ich weil lua steht auf so komische was ist
das aber seht ihr das auch oder oder bin ich guck ich schäb die klammern sind nicht
gleich auf ok ich guck schäb das war wohl nur auf meiner schriftgröße guck mal die
klammern sind nicht gleich auf seht ihr das auf meiner schriftgröße sind die klammern
sind nicht nicht nicht in der gleichen zeile jetzt ist ok guck mal es ist nur auf mein überall
anders überall anders ist top in ordnung aber auf die nur auf meiner schriftgröße
ist es broken alles ok ich habe exakt die schriftgröße getroffen wo es broken ist
das ist bestimmt nicht so eine anti allasing geschichte die verkackt maus bindings so da
kommt jetzt immer hier fort so in die maus bindings kommt jetzt schon mal das default
das defaulting rein was ich immer haben will das da ok wunderbar kein sündungsfehler kein
sündungsfehler excellent und jetzt will ich irgendwas hier anhängen weil ich noch nichts
anderes drauf hab lua append how do i append to a table in lua nee so schau mal nicht wo
ist mein dark reader font finder brauche ich nicht mehr wo ist mein dark reader plugins
pensions wie hatte ich kein dark reader nee ich hatte ich hatte gar keinen dark reader
install ich habe firefox auf dark theme umgestellt was aber alleine ja nicht reicht weil die
das gerne nur bei seiten geht die was anbieten da so viel viel viel viel schöner viel exzellent
also wie konnte man das table insert ja richtig skandal warum hat es der gopher flow eigentlich
kein dark mode also sowas brauchen wir jetzt hier table insert in die table maus bindings
wenn man das jetzt so richtig schreiben kann maus bindings will ich einfügen will ich
in die table maus bindings einfügen das da oder das da so müsste das eigentlich funktionen
ja hoffentlich habe ich keinen sündungsfehler produziert okay sieht nicht so aus nice nice
nice und jetzt sagen wir streak streak ist e jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
und jetzt sagen wir maus bindings gleich maus bei falls das geht so und jetzt sollte ich
100 mal die mittlere maustaste angelegt haben gucken wir mal bäme bäme funst leute bäme
komm mal hier klick klick klick klick klick oh fuck was mache ich jetzt habe jetzt gemacht
erst mal nicht speichern klick klick klick klick klick klick klick klick klick klick
geht geht instant mittlere maustaste aber maximal 100 mal beim 100er streak hört er
auf aber ich glaube 100 mal die mittlere maustaste in folge werde ich eher nicht so aufdrücken
das ist nicht schön ich gehe davon aus dass es bestimmt besser geht wenn man sich mit
der config näher auseinander gesetzt hat aber bis dahin bleibt das so so und jetzt kümmern
wir uns mal ein paar andere sachen weil terminal haben wir jetzt haben wir jetzt erstmal genug
hübsch hübsch gemacht mach lieber 1000 1000 mal drücke ich noch nicht meine wir haben
im firefox eingestellt dass er da seite mitteilen soll dass man dark mode bevorzugt und wenn
stack overflow das nicht nicht beachtet dann pains jam sind hier die klammern die klammern
sind auf meiner schriftgröße verschoben wahnsinn ich meine wir können mal ttf ttf hack aninstallen
ttf hack mit icons drinnen installieren das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich e oh was ist jetzt
kaputt a hack hack ist broken ok was wow wow wow alter ist ja gut please nicht eskalieren
emojis font konfig match nee nach was muss ich suchen und konfig list ist es hack wie
heißt der krempel jetzt hack hack regular hack not font brauche ich jetzt hack ups jetzt
sollte es auch funktionieren ja das ist gut jetzt ist alles wieder und klammern immer
noch procken alter ich habe ernsthaft seriously ich habe es geschafft die einzige schrift
dann die einzige schrift größe zu finden wo die klammern nicht richtig allein sind
das ist ja wahnsinn das kann nicht sein hier eine animation ne will ich nicht einbauen
ich meine das müsste man müsste man sich jetzt für bash für bash raussuchen ok animation
in bash ein spinnender spinnender progress balken top ist das nur in dem terminal so
weiß ich nicht gucken wir mal wie es hier ist hier ist es nicht so aber das ist ja auch
nur in dieser einen schrift größe so wartet mal advanced advanced default colors erst mal
das da oder was auch immer so und jetzt brauchen wir schriftgröße hack regular hier ist es
nicht so wobei das vielleicht wobei hier vielleicht nicht exakt die richtige schriftgröße treffe
das kann ja schon sein aber witzig was habe ich denn hier für eine schriftgröße ich
glaube was habe ich denn hier gehabt 15 15 ist 12 das ist auch so mit schriftgröße 15
ist davon geil normalerweise verwende ich 16 ohne scheiß ich habe jetzt extra eins runter
geschaltet weil normalerweise habe ich 16 ich habe seit jahren schon 16 aber ich habe eins
runter geschaltet weil ich mir gedacht habe die größe ist immer noch gut aber es passt
ein bisschen mehr drauf seriously es ist einfach procken was ein schwachsinn man ok erst mal
den kram installieren ich ehrlich gesagt ich kann ich kann damit aber leben das bleibt
jetzt erst mal so alles klar so ich würde sagen mit terminal sind wir jetzt erst mal
durch was machen wir denn als nächstes wenn sie nehmen ein paar sachen wenn sie den flame
shot flame shot beste flame shot ist eine screenshot anwendung die richtig nice ist
wenn es nicht kennt ich zeige euch das mal flame shot bäms da unten jetzt kann man sagen
macht mir mal ein screenshot und escape machen wir mal ein screenshot und screenshot hiervon
und jetzt kann man hier sogar editieren kann man drauf rummalen oder kann man was das nochmal
ein rectangle kann man machen und feile guck mal so youtube youtube thumbnails man kann
blurr man kann text drauf machen heckl man kann auch irgendwie die farbe ändern das in
den settings dann und du also ist richtig ist richtig gut gemacht custom uploader das weiß
ich nicht ich benutze nie die eingebaute upload funktionalität von diesen dingern das weiß
ich nicht ob es mehr kann als im imigurr so was kann es hier noch circle marker text auto
increment counter bubble was auch immer man damit machen soll
man kann sachen blurr das ist sehr praktisch
kann die selection area move na gut warte mal warte mal ist meine ich dachte meine katze
ist an der tür ja und dann kann man dann kann man speicher natürlich oder uploaden
mal gucken ob es mittlerweile mehr gibt ein auge so hell kann man die preset farben eingeben
so was hier auf jeden fall ausschalten die welcome message hat es hat es in dark theme
mittlerweile oder sieht man da wirklich ganz ganz schlecht was ne ok es ist immer noch
nur im imigurr es geht nicht und flame schon auch keine hat auch kein dark theme weil das
überhaupt nicht wild ist ehrlich gesagt ich meine die settings wie oft macht man die
auf aber das ist wirklich saumäßig nice screenshot program hat das tooltags der kennung
ich glaube nicht ich weiß ich kann es gifs ich glaube ich glaube gifs kann es auch nicht
ne ne ne kann es nicht das wäre witzig wenn es auch noch gift könnte aber das finde ich
nicht schlimm total fall capture ich schnell mit obs was gif gifs gibt es nicht
das vhs sowie sowie die videokassette cli home video recorder für gifs written in go
dann terminal gifs from code ich will ja ich will ja nicht zwangsläufig nur terminal aufnehmen
das ist was anderes also flameshot ist nice aber ich glaube flameshot kann nix anderes
als imigurr upload provider oder so ne custom domain uploading uploader custom domain uploader
it's much easier to use a wrapper script for that ja kann man machen
ok man kann einfach flameshot starten und das bild dann irgendwo hinpipen ja das ist
ok das ist dann ist easy dann kann man dann braucht es das auch nicht wirklich eingebaut
aber ich würde es eh nur für lokale screenshots benutzen also aber das flameshot ist wirklich
sehr nice geschichte was brauchen wir dann sonst noch lass mal lass mal kurz überlegen
also das mit caps lock das haben wir schon gemacht caps lock ist disabel firefox wo
wir gerade dabei sind auch noch das dark theme oder firefox alpenclaw meine auge enable
viel besser so jetzt firefox auch komplett dark gethemed ich hab einen 1008 sp modder
richtig richtig 1008 sp 240 hz so also das haben wir gemacht dann also das mit caps lock
haben wir gemacht so icons flameshot haben wir auch so icons ok da müssen wir tatsächlich
mal gucken weil also auch auch wegen dieser leiste da unten ich meine die leiste so wirklich
das ist nix da das kannst du das kannst du nicht verwenden also aktuell verwende ich
das ei3 status rust das ist ehrlich gesagt absolut in ordnung das ist fein kann man
sich auch nicht beschweren also das macht was es soll aber ich habe was anderes gefunden
das hier das macht auch einen ganz guten eindruck wird beides relativ aktiv entwickelt relativ
ja damit kann man auch verschiedene status status dinger generieren und das allerwichtigste
eigentlich müssten wir das verwendet weil das ist written in rust und das hier ist written
in python oder go in python und nicht rust also da müsste man eigentlich müsste man
das weiterverwenden weil playsingly fast kennst du polybar ja kenne ich auch es gibt hunderte
dieser dieser status aus gaben dinger weiß gar nicht was ich da von ihm ganz ehrlich
theoretisch könnten wir dabei bleiben weil das habe ich schon habe ich schon eine config
für und eigentlich alles ist alles gut wir schauen jetzt noch mal kurz was ich nämlich
auch ausprobieren wollte ist so ein auto auto start autostart ding das steht nämlich in
der ei3 config mit in der ei3 config mittlerweile standardmäßig sogar drin da dachte ich mir
so schlecht kann es nicht sein wenn die default config das schon das schon mit mit rein haut
sagen wir flame schott noch mal dass es automatisch starten soll zack und jetzt probieren wir das
mal aus mal jetzt mal bäm ups bäm desktop abschießen neu einloggen und gucken ob alles
automatisch startet ja macht er macht er ok nice übrigens bestes bestes hintergrund
hintergrund bild wisst ihr für alle die gestern nicht dabei waren wisst ihr wie wir dieses
bild erstellt haben also die ursprüngliche variante ist von reddit allerdings bloß 940
pixel 940 pixel 940 pixel irgendwie preis ist zu low res zu low res und wir haben das
mit ei abgescaled ei ei ei ei abscaling kam jetzt dieses bild dabei raus das ist ein
ei people sieht man hier an den konturen ein bisschen ein mikrofon ist verzerrt war es
jetzt schon wieder sekunde sekunde mikrofon test lulvee mikrofon test lulvee hört eigentlich
ganz normal an vielleicht eben gerade eben gerade habe ich halb halb über dem tisch
tisch gehauen und und hatte das halb im mund stecken so hier guck eben hatte ich das so
da hört sich ein bisschen kacke an das stimmt jetzt auch asmr videos machen
gut ja da weiß ich nicht was wir genau was wir da gescheit gescheit verwenden also ok
ja aber so was von by the way by the way arch so wie hat der typ das jetzt hinbekommen
das denn ein icon da drin ich will eigentlich nicht weiter am terminal basteln das reicht
mir jetzt erstmal aber guck mal die haben sogar hier irgendwelche fancy fancy hintergrund
in der taskbar das schon das schon nice irgendjemand hat doch eben vorhin was geschickt wo ich
gesagt habe da muss ich mal gucken zwar irgendwie tepp bar style konky ja wenn man wenn man
drauf steht irgendwelche sachen im hintergrund anzuzeigen ist das ganz nice aber ich brauche
ich nicht ich gucke eh selten auf dem desktop also insofern hier kommen können wir mal
installieren es ist kein multiplexer wie t max aber du kannst so sachen hier machen die
ähnlich sind so t max also für lokal ist es super remote über ssh kann musst du weiter
t max verwenden also eigentlich genauso wie es sein soll ansonsten ich habe ähnliche
mappings wie auf t max nur dass es kein t max ist es sieht aber schon mit der leiste hier
unten auch verdächtig verdächtig ähnlich persistence ich weiß ich ob es so was wie
sessions hat hat es sessions es hat workspaces irgendwie geht so was workspaces kann man
irgendwie machen switch workspace relativ switch to workspace ja also irgendwie irgendwas
geht hier aber damit habe ich das müssen wir erst beim detail beschäftigen wenn du
jetzt noch t max start das hast du dann zwei border ja hätte ich auf jeden fall aber ich
habe es gar nicht mehr installiert weil ich erste mal ich werde es auch erst mal nicht
mehr nicht mal benutzen lokal weil ich die sache guck jetzt hast du zwei sachen logischer
weise jetzt kannst du die leute ganz verwirren mit sowas remote werde ich auf jeden fall
weiter verwenden remote ist es bei uns auf der arbeit auch eines der standard tools schlechthin
die verwendet jeder gerade remote sessions offen wo man dann sagt hey kann man kurz was
zusammen gucken und sowas ist wirklich nice hier die kommen geben erst mal ein bisschen
transparenz leute ohne transparenz geht hier nix die kommen und wie ging jetzt transparenz
noch einmal da muss ich da muss ich mal in meine eigenen in meine eigene config reingucken
von von der alten kiste config p com fading gleich falls nie das war was anderes ich glaube
die standard i3 bar konnte keine transparenz das das ist es glaube ich ja weil jetzt macht
er so komische überblenden dinger beim desktop wechseln das das triggert mich immer das
geht das dauert mir viel zu lang guck mal leute wenn du den desktop wechselt und er
faded erst mal so da drehste drehste voll ab weil ich meine sieht es schön schön smooth
und weich aus aber ich mag es überhaupt nicht deswegen mkdir config p com config und dann
wie heißt die datei p com konf da kommt jetzt ist da rein fading gleich falls und jetzt
faded da einfach auch nix mehr jetzt schaltet er jetzt schaltet einfach direkt um easy und
wir haben transparenz aber das guck mal das hintergrund durchschreien hatte das auch ohne
p com nee da hat er das gar nicht vielleicht sollte ich p com einfach komplett rauslassen
ich hatte früher p com weil ich kann euch sagen weil die die performance im browser
teilweise bisschen bisschen bisschen mies war also gerade beim scroll und wenn sich wenn
sich viel im browser bewegt hat hat es geruckelt und das war was heißt geruckelt da war es
nicht so nicht so smooth wie es sein könnte und das ist mit p com ein bisschen gefühlt
ein bisschen besser wenn man hier wenn man hier scrollt wobei ich sagen muss auf dem
neuen rechner ist es kaum noch kaum noch zu spüren also vielleicht vielleicht lasse
ich das einfach auch ganz weg ich meine wozu nee nee ich brauche es für die transparenz
ich brauche es für die transparenz von der von der leiste ohne sonst gibt es nicht ohne
ich brauche brauche transparenz sonst sonst das nervt mich wenn das hier unten also ich
zeige es euch mal bei meiner alten form bei meiner alten form sieht das so aus jede da
habe ich hinten transparenz in der leiste so muss das sein ich finde den slider rechts
ist viel zu schmal welcher slider rechts das da bei firefox ja das verwende ich normalerweise
auch nie ich mache immer mausrad scrolling oder hier bild hoch bild runter und post eins
und ende wir richten weiter und meine die die linux vm ein soll wir gucken jetzt mal dass
wir unordentlich status leiste hinkriegen weil so ist das ziemlich ziemlich hippiger
ich brauche tatsächlich ein file manager normalerweise benutze ich eigentlich terminal für nahezu
alles aber ab und zu ab und zu brauchen wir noch ein file manager hauptsächlich zum beispiel
für weil es am besten damit geht von windows rein track und drop copy pasten guck wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel das hier von windows rein pasten will also rein pasten geht noch
rein pasten geht noch weil wenn man das in die shell macht ich kann euch das mal zeigen
wenn man das in die shell macht dann kriege ich den fad hier rein kopiert das geht gar
nicht mehr interessant
achja früher konnte man das auf die shell kopieren dann hat man hier den fad gehabt
guck mal da oben was da oben jetzt in der ecke hängt so allein schon deswegen braucht man
den gui in den gui file manager wenn man von seinem host ab und zu mal was track und dropen
will guck mal ich hab's kaputt gemacht jetzt hängt da oben das ding wir haben vmw wir haben
vmw geprägt mal gucken ob es funktioniert wenn ich das man jaro nein arch by the way das ist ein
original art stören nicht die 60 herz von vmw eigentlich nö oh jetzt habe ich was kaputt gemacht
close ich hab's ich hab's geprägt zum komischen copy copy paste versuch komplett vom scratch
genau restore session war im kaputt also zum zum copy paste brauche ich diesen diesen file manager
zum beispiel wenn ich das hier wenn ich stream kopieren will in meinem explorer zum beispiel
das geht nur gescheit mit dem gui mit dem gui file manager und deswegen müssen wir das
gerade noch ein bisschen bisschen verschönern die icons muss ich sagen sie mittlerweile wirklich
in ordnung mit dem file manager ja das funktioniert mit track und drop nicht richtig wie gesagt
es muss das muss eine gui anwendung sein dass vmw das checkt normalerweise habe ich gar
keinen also wenn ich das nicht in der vmw zähle habe ich gar keinen gui file manager achtung
blend plant granate und maus ist eigentlich absolut in ordnung icon theme ist auch ok
ich brauche mir gar nichts anpassen doch wir passen an show images und buttons
kann tuner tabs ich habe keine ahnung ich war wie gesagt ich verwende das nur zum track und
dropen aus und in die vm ansonsten eigentlich gar nichts ich glaube nicht dass es tabs kann
oder split view ok anscheinend anscheinend kannst du irgendwie mehrere sachen aufmachen
kann kann tabs echt wie kontrolle t tatsächlich kann tabs interessant roste schnell
dies ist mir neu war mir so nicht bewusst
war mir so gar nicht plus ich verwende das ich verwende das normalerweise auch gar nicht
nur für track und drop aus und in die vm so das ist schon mal ganz nice ok wie entlocken
wir dem ding da unten denn jetzt mal transparenz du hast github poli bar also ich habe poli bar
noch nie verwendet es ist es gibt so viele sachen es gibt es gibt poli pie es gibt die
drei status rs es gibt bumblebee es gibt i3 status selbst es gibt total viel zeug bisher
habe ich mich noch nicht mit poli bar auseinander gesetzt was wie heißt das ding eww ist das
für ein ding es gibt da so viel zeug von was el covers wacky widgets alles klar es
gibt so viel zeug man oh made in rost leute
dann ist ja eigentlich schon mal klar was wir nehmen müssen oder
wir haben die auswahl zwischen nicht written in rost und written in rost
steht auch was von blazingly fast drinne ne das davon habe ich beispielsweise noch nie was
gehört wacky widgets widgets system made in rost
which lets you create your own widgets
na das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben jetzt da kannst du quasi komplett mit gtk oder so
eigene eigene bars zusammenzimmern das ist wie das ist dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen
bisschen overkill punkt jack ist das lisp ist das lisp ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne leute
mit einem komischen lisp dialekt fangen wir jetzt nicht an auf gar keinen fall
lisp ist so ziemlich das hässlichste was es gibt gibt es gibt es paar gescheite examples von
poli bar so was kann man dann hier machen docks
ich meine ich könnte auch einfach das nehmen was ich bisher genommen habe weil ich bin damit
voll voll voll und ganz zufrieden ehrlich gesagt das sieht dann so aus ungefähr
samples
screenshots
kein image
sieht dann so aus ist das was ich bisher meine alten vm hatte u launcher anstatt rofi ne warum
das denn also rofi finde ich ist das beste u launcher was ist der vorteil deiner meinung
nach von u launcher
versus also ich finde rofi ist eine super geschichte kannst du clipboard integrieren
kannst du emoji selection rein machen alles mögliche
finde ich finde ich super super geschichte
das dem müssen wir übrigens auch noch ist der der abkratz fällt mir gerade so ein
ad menu haben wir aktuell gerade aber es dürfte ein bisschen ein bisschen schicker dürfte
schon sein mein rofi setup hier das was ich die ganze zeit verwendet die window icon sind
für mich das killer feature welche window icons du meinst dass da auch das die fenster
durchsuchen kannst
also ich habe ich habe einmal rofi für meinen clipboard manager und zum starten von programm
so das sind eigentlich die zwei sachen die ich verwende
firefox zack starten copy paste einfügen
es das habe ich bei mir habe ich bei mir in der in der terminal history
u launcher wie sieht das ding überhaupt aus u launcher ist das ist das eine node.js anwendung
irgendwie schreit es ein bisschen node.js
kannst du die register mit dem clipboard manager auch mit wim verbinden ich klicke im clipboard
manager das an und dann wird es in system clipboard kopiert und dann kann ich es auch
in wim einfügen das unterstützt nicht 95 nicht die 95
verschiedenen wim clipboards aus was ist denn das pyson ok
rofi ist glaube ich c++ monkaS
scroll noch ein stück runter
wo hier
ja
so du meinst die bilder wie die aussehen
wahrscheinlich ist da ein bisschen auch noch
ist da vielleicht doch ein embedded browser dahinter irgendwie
könnte das sein
also ich bin mit rofi wirklich sehr zufrieden
ich wüsste nicht warum ich das switchen sollte
und wird beides super aktiv entwickelt ist das für alle die es benutzen also was was
spricht was spricht er jetzt was spricht er jetzt dagegen
ich meine wir können es einfach mal installieren ich meine wir sind ja hier um neue sachen
auszuprobieren
ok es gibt schon mal kein offizielles kein offizielles package
nur user repos das ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlimm aber es ist doof
wir nehmen den wo ist er denn
rofi emoji das brauchen wir unbedingt
ok es gibt es gibt rofi moji und rofi emoji was ist denn jetzt was ist denn davon besser
wir installieren das ding erstmal 29
paru wurde mir gestern schon vorgeschlagen den sinn nicht drin gesehen
rofi moji haben wir zur auswahl was rofi moji ich mache übrigens noch kein emoji picker
also vielleicht ist das ja mal was neues
rofi emoji gibts beides also wir haben die auswahl zwischen irgendwas was aktiv entwickelt
wird und was nicht also nehmen wir rofi moji
im Prinzip machen sie beide mehr oder weniger das gleiche
emoji selektor character picker ja main features
na gut dann probieren wir das mal aus rofi moji moji
alles klar gib ihm
also jetzt haben wir das optional dependencies wozu
ach wayland wayland zeug
nee brauchen wir nicht
habe ich hab eigentlich ein nerdfont installiert
ich hab den die nerdfont hack habe ich installiert
gtf also ich weiß nicht warum man da meinung ist dass ich das nicht habe
aber gut
ok und jetzt rofi bäm da isser
achja das hat jetzt sogar das hat jetzt sogar einen assistent zu irgendwas in der richtung
das ist jetzt auch neu
also rofi moji
so wo ist das problem doch meine tastatur ist wunderbar um characters zu typen
achso ach zum einfügen ok
ok leuchtet ein
rofi moji ah da sind wir
kackel gibt es nicht
wie ist wie ist dieses emoji wo alle ein problem mit haben hier
das da
lächeln das gesicht mit lachen lächeln das gesicht es ist englisch
meine browser sprache muss ich noch umstellen ganz wichtig
wo ich habe mir language
hier habe ich doch
choose your preferred language englisch
warum komme ich dann hier auf deutsch raus google google angeboten auf englisch jo viel
besser
und jetzt komme ich auch auf der englischen seite raus ok
also smiling muss ich suchen smiling smiling face with
so was ist das smiling einfach nur smiling face das ist das wo das ding so rum baggt
smiling face with smiling eyes
das normale das normale ist da schon gar nicht mehr drinne
so das ist natürlich auch praktisch ach guck mal der merkt sich der merkt sich tatsächlich
auch was man zuletzt eingefügt hat
guck mal wenn ich das jetzt noch mal aufmache jetzt weiß er ich hab ich hab das hier so
die top die top 10 emojis die ich irgendwie verwendet hab
und wie kann ich die jetzt auswählen wie kann ich die jetzt selecten
wenn ich das noch mal einfügen will
thinking haben wir noch ja cool
so und wie wie wie wie bekomme ich jetzt dahin
123 wie funktioniert das
mit alt also sprich zwei dann kommt die katze
sehr praktisch finde ich finde ich nice
muss ich ehrlich sagen gefällt mir besser als das windows ding
so jetzt müssen wir erstmal den theme selektor
was hatte ich noch mal für den theme das nicht das nicht das nicht das nicht das nicht
das nicht das nicht das nicht das auch nicht
das auch nicht
gleich kommt hier diese komische schildkröte leute wo ich mich jedes mal frage warum ist
das überhaupt dabei
ja kann ich dir gleich zeigen das geht ganz gut das ist nix
ist nix nix nix das geht noch halbwegs
ist die schildkröte wieder das ist echt das ist glaube ich einfach nur irgendwie aus
spaß da drin aus so just for fun keine ahnung
egi
monokat paper purple sidebar
jetzt haben wir es jetzt haben wir es gebrocken
ok mein theme ist da gar nicht dabei
wo habe ich denn das her
was verwende ich denn da moment da muss ich jetzt mal kurz abgucken
was habe ich denn da
das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool was ich was ich hier am start habe bei dem alten
was ist das für ein theme
aber less konfig ruf konfig
das da
ne
Das war die alte, die alte V-M, Rofi Slate.
This repository has been archived.
Warum wurde das archived?
Das ist aber doof.
Ja, da müssen wir uns eines der offiziellen, eines der offiziellen Themes aussuchen.
Okay, was taucht noch am ehesten?
Android Notification.
Äh, das sieht doch alles, das sieht doch alles, dark blue demon.
Okay, die Schildkröte werde ich nicht nehmen.
Die gefallen mir alle nicht, das geht ja noch am ehesten klar, glaube ich.
Das gefällt mir alles nicht.
Das sieht alles doof aus, was soll denn das sein, da erkennst du ja gar nichts.
Okay, keine Ahnung, das ist alles, gibt es da irgendwie neues, Themes Collection.
Gibt es da vielleicht im Repo welche?
Okay, da gibt es User Repost, das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Rofi, ich meine die machen ja schon mal ganz gute Sachen, das ist ja eine eigene Distribution.
Okay, was bin ich sehend, Chat, was ihr mir hier gepostet habt.
Launchers, a huge collection of Rofi based custom Applets, Launchers und Power Menus.
Okay, Setup, Edit, Launchers, was, einer hat jetzt wieder 30 Milliarden Sachen dabei.
Ja, das sieht schon mal deutlich, deutlich schicker aus als das andere, Style 1.
Ja, das finde ich sehr nett, sowas, Adapter, Arc, Black, Cat Poutine, One Dark, das sieht
schick aus, glaube ich, ja, das sind so Sachen, das ist in Ordnung, ja, das finde ich, finde
ich ganz, ganz schick, Loveless, das kann man, das kann man sich alles geben, ja, kann
man installieren, also wie funktioniert das, Launchers, oh, das ist schick, das gefällt,
ne, was, das ist aber kein Rofi, oder, oder doch, was passiert da gerade, was passiert
hier, was, was sehe ich da überhaupt, okay, das verwirrt mich, was ich, was das überhaupt
ist, wie sieht das bei dem aus, okay, wie funktioniert das ganze, Rofi, Themes, Rofi
Theme Launcher, das ist das hier, Large Collection, oder, da gibt es ein User Repo von, Arch,
das ist, das ist das hier, oder, was es da über das User Repo gibt, würde ich jetzt,
würde ich jetzt mal sagen, Huge Collection, das ist das hier, Power Menu Launcher, ich
checke allerdings ehrlich gesagt nicht, was der Unterschied ist, Rofi Theme Used, Rofi
Theme Power Menu, Rofi Theme Launcher, Applets, da bin ich, da bin ich zu Low IQ für, was
jetzt was ist, Applets, Battery, da muss, da muss studieren, das ist richtig, richtig
high IQ Zeug, ich installiere das jetzt mal, Launcher, Applets, Power Menüs, hat Power
Menüs was zu tun mit Batterie oder so, ach so, nee, das ist quasi so eine Art Plugin
dafür, okay, also installieren wir mal, was haben wir denn hier, Breeze, Rofi Theme Menu,
Rofi Theme Menu, Launcher, was mich schon wieder verwirrt, ist, dass es hier tausend verschiedene
Packages von gibt, und wie kommen die auf irgendwelche Versionen, der Typ hat auch nie
eine Version released bisher, egal, schauen wir mal, was haben wir hier, First Man, Clone,
Changed, Clone, Directory, Setup und dann Setup ausführen, naja, ich bin da eigentlich
immer so ein bisschen, wie kommen, wie kommen die Jungs hier auf die Versionsnummer, Version,
was macht denn das Setup, install Fonts, Alter, das installiert mir wieder 30 Milliarden Sachen
auf meinem System, ja anscheinend gibt es keinen User, da musst du wirklich studieren
dafür, wisst ihr was, installieren ist jetzt einfach mal easy, wir haben noch, wir haben
noch eine VM, wir haben noch eine VM, schade doch nichts, Clone, ich muss sagen, ich mach
so Sachen eigentlich ungern, ich benutze mittlerweile ehrlich gesagt am liebsten halbwegs offizielle
Packages ohne so viel dazu zu machen, weil es breakt halt ab und zu mal und du weißt
dann immer nicht genau, woran es jetzt liegt, ok, Setup, auf gehts, installed successfully,
ok, Fonts, ok, irgendwas, also, dann, Profil, Teamselector, habe ich jetzt mehr zur Auswahl,
doch nicht wirklich, oder, und, was mach ich jetzt, that's it, Teams are now installed on
your system, ok, ja, ja, ok, und jetzt, ist da irgendwas Neues jetzt dabei gekommen, nee,
neu starten, edit, hier, edit, config, rofi, launchers, script, Datei gibt es nicht, Alter,
was zum Teufel ist das denn, wie soll man denn da durchblicken, man, config, rofi, colors,
ok, da ist der Krempel schon mal, One Dark steht ja auch nicht drinnen, vielleicht muss
ich erstmal initial ein Theme auswählen, das sich die config Datei anlegt, ok, ich nehme
jetzt einfach das default Theme und sag, wie save man das denn, Accept, Steuerung A, ok,
config, rofi, launchers, Type, ach, jetzt muss ich auswählen, welchen Launcher Type
ich haben will, also nehmen wir jetzt type, type 2, type 3, ok, type 3, type 3, und, und
jetzt, das ist, ok, die config is weird, weird champ, edit the script and edit the following
line to use the style you like, style minus 1, was, Moment, Launcher, ok, ok, ok, ok,
type 2, ach, type 3 gibt es da nochmal verschiedene Themes, oder wie?
Richtig, richtig high-rq Shit, Alter, bis man da dahinter gekommen ist, ok, ich lass
jetzt mal das default, kann man das jetzt einfach ausführen, такие, ah, das ist ganz
schick, das ist eigentlich ganz nice, Leute, das ist ein ganz, relativ hübscher, crochetser
launcher ein hübscher launcher
Und wie change man jetzt die color
Das machten der typ noch hat er noch mehr so design stellskram
rofi archcraft
das ist archcraft
polybar themes ach der typ ist das
ist dynamic wallpaper ok interessant was hatten der noch alles
in thermos ach das ist dieses android terminal ding sort bei
kann man die repos konnte man die repos nicht irgendwie nach sternen sortieren
ach jedoch stars
der typ hat er sau viel gut gut designte sachen anscheinend
hier hast du beispielsweise boot boot logos und sowas
ja warum nicht was sind denn slim themes ach ein login manager ok archcraft
das ist eine das ist eine coole idee ich meine ich gucke meinen hintergrund nie
an ja und es bleibt bei mir der pippo happy im hintergrund aber die idee ist
cool die gefällt mir der hat bestimmt auch so eine designer kaffeemaschine für
8 8 9000 euro ja bestimmt das ist aber die idee ist die idee ist cool man
bräuchte pippo happy quasi in verschiedenen in verschiedenen ausgaben
beispielsweise jetzt müsste es müsste das quasi in so in bettke pose anzeigen
das wäre cool oder pippo happy daily morgens so verschlafen danach essen zähne
putzen dann irgendwann mittagessen und irgendwann abends bettke time
müssen wir mal in den fiver fiver designer beauftragte so was zu
erstellen die dynamic pippo wallpaper ja i may be slow to responde responde so
schnell du willst und das sieht auch schick aus das finde ich ganz nett hier
von dem typ und das ist nicht so overkill das sind einfach sind einfach ein paar
sieben und fern ok wenn also wenn das wenn das mal nicht meck ios meck meck
us geklaut ist dann weiß ich auch nicht gut ok es heißt auch schon spotlight
dass ich schon äußerst stark inspiriert ja aber das finde ich finde ich ganz
bestimmt nicht unter linux ich glaube das ist mir fast lieber so ein mini man
einfach nur ein paar themes installiert ich mein was mit dem tut hier los das
ist ja besteht ja aus 30 milliarden verschiedene sachen ok zumindest so kann
man das so kann man das starten ist eigentlich ist eigentlich auch ganz nett
ist eigentlich ist eigentlich auch ganz cool
da gibt es jetzt was noch verschiedene typen davon launcher typ 123 also wir
können hier beispielsweise launcher typ 1 machen das sieht dann so aus oder
launcher typ 2 das sieht dann so aus ok ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht dann
haben wir noch launcher typ 3 sieht so aus launcher typ 4 sieht so aus launcher
typ 5 monka es
1 durch suchen kackel aber man ist wenn man es wenn man es braucht
window durch suchen
run ja hat er keine eignung ist richtig ane bei apps immer richtig
so dann haben wir sieben
alle sieben hört auf
b top plus plus fällt du launch terminal
excellent
naja gut so und das gibt es jetzt noch type 3 gibt es jetzt noch in
unterschiedlichen also der typ übertreibt sie wirklich oder mit mit
complicated machen weil die dinger gibt es jetzt auch noch in styles die gibt es
jetzt auch noch in verschiedenen styles also sprich typ 3 wir haben typ 3 und
den gibt es jetzt irgendwie noch mal in ja ich weiß ja nicht wie viel styles typ 3
hat zehn verschiedene styles also fangen wir an 1 wir machen es mal so da
kommen besser besser editieren mit miss ich brauche unbedingt ich muss
unbedingt zsh installieren ich brauche gescherte ich brauche
gescherte history und sowas ist es sonst hallo hallo das ist doch sonst mist
ok ups mann was mache ich denn da so jetzt ist es ein bisschen transparent
auch gar nicht mal so übel style 2 ok komplett transparent das ist nix style
kenne ich keinen unterschied erkennt ihren unterschied style 4 gefällt bis
jetzt gefällt mir der am besten wobei wobei wobei wobei ich das ja ehrlich
gesagt horizontal mehr mag dann haben wir style 5 ok den finde ich finde ich
auch nicht schlecht da gefällt mir die schrift hat nicht das installiert mir
aber auch ein bisschen zu viel zeug ok bitte bitte noch bitte noch fetter
alles style 7 ok das ganze in ordnung style 8 das ist links ne links hängen
ist doof ok jetzt hängt der kram rechts und als letztes wieder zehn ich weiß
nicht das ist auch so der hängt auch so viel zeug dran mann ich probiere das
mal hiermit aus moment wir machen jetzt wir machen das von dem anderen du noch
mal ich meine der hat launcher configs am start
applets für irgendwie allen möglichen krempel für volume anpassen screenshot
machen was ist das ist mein schon wieder weil es gibt so viele programme unter
linux beim take screenshots from your desktop ja gut da habe ich da habe ich
da habe ich jetzt ja feier schott für
an das gifs
ok dann kannst du bookmarks screenshot brightness battery apps
immerhin eins muss ich immer zugute halten der hat überall der hat überall
schöne bilder dass du das im vorfeld angucken kannst
im car snip ganz ehrlich flame schott ist mega nice da kannst du jetzt auch rum
mal das ist ein halbes paint mann kann das gips wenn es gips kann würde ich
würde ich gleich nehmen da brauche ich kein obs für gips
das wegen habe ich immer noch share x unter windows das kann das
ok serious max sagt was hast du launcher typ 2 style 2 style 2 ok
der geht tatsächlich ganz gut klar aber ich ich mache mal kurz das andere hin
ganz ehrlich das erscheint mir rofi theme collection einfach geht clone und
gutes installing themes cd repos zack geht clone ja gut das
habe ich copy your desire theme machen wir
pique pique hat übelst viel memory usage gibt es das gar nicht was local
und fick rofi moment die themes kommen wieder woanders hin oder was kann sich
wieder nicht entscheiden oder was oder wie oder wo was ist das hier und brauche
man dafür schon wieder den extra ordner
keck weight cp themes also cd rofi theme collection ok zack copy wir kopieren
einfach alle hin bäm cd da haben wir es so und jetzt kommen die können wir
hoffentlich hoffentlich im theme collector auswählen jetzt ja ok ok sieht
schon besser aus also das sind glaube ich alle die mitgeliefert werden bis hier
hin und jetzt so launchpad ok schon mal bronken schon mal bronken
funktionieren die icons nicht nord one line nord nord 2 line nord rounded rounded
common ist bronken nice sehr gut gg eats funktioniert ja wunderbar ganz toll
das sieht aber auf der auf der webseite von dem dude deutlich deutlich nicer
aus ok probier uns mal aus except ok jetzt starten wir das mal rofi wie ist
der wie ist der app launcher dafür die run die run nee das war aus dem kopf
land wie startet man den den d d ran show show
ah ja das da ist eigentlich ganz ok tatsächlich kann man tatsächlich ganz
gut mit leben ja das immer kurz auf der webseite von dem typ gucken was da
also windows 11 werde ich garantiert passbar auf passbar windows 11 list
dank ja wunderbar naja gut an windows an windows 11 erinnert
mich das jetzt nicht wirklich es ist in der mitte ok das war es aber
squared nord das ist auch ganz gut ich muss euch sagen das alte was ich die
ganze zeit hatte gefällt mir immer noch am besten spotlight dark war glaube ich
auch ganz gut simpel tokyo night was ist das
rounded rounded war bronken round war bronken
launchpad launchpad probieren wir mal aus und tokyo
den moment das hängt dann irgendwie an der seite das schon mal misst
die weg
nicht die rounded wie ist das andere jetzt mein gott ich habe gedächtnis gerade
launchpad war das genau launchpad show es ist auch ok ich weiß nicht ganz
ehrlich mein mein aktuelles mein aktuelles sieben gefällt mir eigentlich
am besten das ist wirklich halber gnome bsit der scheiß gnome bsit
ja ja gnome hat es ja auch
ach ich weiß nicht also überzeugt mich jetzt alles nicht so sehr wenn ich
ehrlich bin
ich lasse mal so ein standard ding mein hübsch ist es nett
das das hat mich das hat mich an komplexität das hat mich ehrlich gesagt
an komplexität ein bisschen überfordert diese launcher von dem du hier typ 2
launcher und es gibt es ja dann auch noch in was wie viele
das ist ganz ehrlich das ist wahrscheinlich so da noch das hier noch
am angenehmsten
da gibt es auch noch unterschiedlich was es gibt auch noch unterschiedlich die
color seams moment
...
Wo, Color?
Ach, du Scheiße!
...
Wart mal voran.
Ach du kacke
Ne habe ich doch das habe ich doch schon alles durch probiert hier die themes
Style 1 2 3 Moment ne ne Moment directory
Dann ist die frage was man hier ok 1 1 dark 1 da
Change colors edit
Ok das ist der bräuchte in den set up script dafür das ist doch abartig da
Da blickt auch da blickt auch keiner mehr durch
Und wo gibt es jetzt gibt es jetzt hier einen vorschau wenigstens für verschiedene color themes oder
Wanda
Ne das muss man dann anscheinend alles selbst ausprobieren
Oder hat er oder hat er bilder previews
Scheiße man
Du kannst einfach
Aufklappen wo denn
Ach hier ah
ok
1 dark 1 dark ist anscheinend die fault
nords
loveless
katz putz hin
Katz putz hin
Der kellmark blautöne nicht so mein fall
Weil man ist jetzt unterschiedliche bilder alles sah alles ähnlich aus
Ok sieht tatsächlich leute ist tatsächlich unterschiedlich es sieht tatsächlich unterschiedlich aus aber nur aber nur minimal
Ne also das ist das ist mir das ist für den launcher doch ein bisschen bisschen zu abgedreht komplex
Ich meine das hier geht das geht durchaus klar wobei mir halt die schriftart nicht wirklich gut gefällt
Ok also was soll ich nehmen das da das ist color 4 das ist color 4 und das ändert mir jetzt
Wie heißt das ding ok
Ok sieht es jetzt anders aus als vorher
Sieht sah das jetzt anders aus ok ich mache mal ein schreibfehler und dann lädt es immer noch
Das hat jetzt sich jetzt nichts geändert gerade
Ok wir machen was was definitiv anders aus
sieht das war irgendwie gelb oder sowas der ändert sich an der optik ja gar nichts da gibt es keine dienste zum durchstarten wir sind nicht unter windows
Jetzt blinke ich jetzt das Bild jetzt hört es bei mir auf jetzt blinke ich nicht mehr durch
Ach colors in type 5 6 und 7 mal hardcoded aber ich habe ich habe ich habe style style 2 und typ 2 da ist es nicht hardcoded
Moment change color habe ich das jetzt richtig editiert
Moment Moment wo habe ich denn hier überhaupt was wo habe ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt editiert
Ich habe in irgendeinem anderen Moment ich habe im falschen ordner editiert
My god alter wie kompliziert ist das blitz type 2 so und da will ich jetzt das da null type 2 so und wie sieht es jetzt aus
Es sieht jetzt anders aus ok wunderbar monka es das ist ja abartig kompliziert workstation ist nicht gratis
Der neue player ist auch nicht mehr gratis da muss man ein bisschen also denn der player ist schon noch gratis
allerdings gibt es jetzt so eine kostflüchtige player variante und vor allem wer hat dafür gesorgt dass wir das dass man das nicht mehr nicht mehr ordentlich findet
Die kostlose variante
Das ist alles was da drin steht wie kann man den font
Wie passt man an rofi den font nochmal an rofi font und configuration
Minus font show minus font keckel das gibt es nicht
Wie habe ich den font wie habe ich den font hier konfiguriert habe ich das in meiner i3 konfig drinne mit dem mit dem font
Das gibt es doch minus font heck ach hier show icons ach show die ran braucht man ok
Rofi show die ran von der display run ok copy pasten wir das mal ok ok so und das können wir jetzt da drinne mal editieren und hier mal hin
Show die run show icons und hack display ein bisschen customisern das ganze
Aber der font ändert sich nicht warum ändert sich der font nicht vielleicht muss ich den font
Ich muss hier als erstes angeben der ist bestimmt im theme irgendwie definiert und man kann das ist mir dass die config ist mir zu zu zu wir
Von diesem von diesem ding
Der nutzt irgendwelche hardcoded
Fonts ach da gibt es da gibt es eine datei für also sprich type
Also müssen wir launchers type fonts ne
Shared fonts fonts ok hack 16 ach ach ok finde ich jetzt schon ein bisschen aber irgendwie gefällt es mir nicht ganz ehrlich
Ich glaube ich kopiere mir mein theme von dem alten rüber muss ich ehrlich sagen ich finde das hier wirklich sehr nice
So richtig ohne das sieht dann einfach nach einer liste aus fertig
Nimm das mit spotlight ok
Das alte ist halt sehr minimalistisch ja es ist halt schlicht ergreifend eine liste untereinander und das war es das ist auch finde ich vollkommen vollkommen ausreichend
Das das andere ist total auf war auch veringeniert
Meinst du meinst das mit spotlight dark das da
Ist eigentlich auch ganz ok oder
Beachtet das überhaupt mein font das beachtet auch nicht mein font und auch nicht mein run icon
Das springt beim suchen zu viel wie verhält sich da mein altes und hier mal starten
Ja das ist mein altes ist viel besser guck mal das das bleibt einfach immer offen auf der klasse das ist besser ja
Das fliegt alles weg gut leute gut dass ich einen nicht da gut dass ich einen snapshot gemacht habe auf snapshot 3
Das sieht man durch dieser ganze shit wieder weg das ist mir alles zu übertrieben und zu kompliziert ich mein seriously was was ist das 500 bash scripts und 30
Um seinen launcher ein bisschen bisschen schick zu machen wir machen jetzt mal gerade just for fun moment rofi theme das da machen wir nochmal
What the hell installiert erst mal einen gnome hinterher leb ichs klavier
Nope also abbrechen abbrechen abbrechen
Wie ist das andere ding u launcher ich meine wir können wir können es ja mal ausprobieren was was irgendeiner im chat alter
Was ist denn hier immer los please was wollen diese dinger was wollen diese dinger mir immer installiert ok das sind das sind make dependencies die kann man
Wir haben mal einen snapshot gemacht ui guck mal abt abt hätte noch nicht mal angefangen jetzt pacman und so das flutscht einfach immer richtig richtig zaggig
U launcher ok lull ok
Reference gibt es da color theme elementary dark reloaded schon mal nicht automatisch schon mal cringe
Packt rum beim fenster resize mann sag mal gibt es da auch gibt es zur abwechslung auch mal irgendwie gescheite software hier guck mal packt rum beim fenster resize wahrscheinlich ist da wahrscheinlich weil sie irgendwie
Wayland support geil finden und ichs nicht mal richtig unterstützt oder was ist das
Reference ist hotkey control space ok brauche ich nicht
Aber eins muss man ihn zugute zu gut halten es sieht zumindest schon mal besser aus als das andere es ist es startet halt einfach
Dafür habe ich da kein clipboard manager integration und sowas ich werde bei rofi bleiben und im zweifelsfall leute zweifelsfall mache ich einfach mir ein eigenes theme weil dazu brauchst du ja realistisch betrachtet musst du drei farben angeben und es ist fertig
Was das deep learning add-in und das hat extensions das was deep translate translate text using deep
Clipboard
Clipboard gibt es auch gibt es vielleicht irgendwas wo ich wo ich einfach nur text rein bekomme
Greenclip oder so angeblich finde der Clipboard irgendwie auf der seite ich sehe es jetzt nicht
Ich will auf jeden fall dann Clipboard Manager drinne haben Clipboard Manager zeigt mal her
Integrated with Clipman Clipstar Copy Q&G Paste
Aber das sind wir irgendwelche third unbeta plugins
Add-extension
Ok
Kann man kann man irgendwas auswählen
So wird das so wird das wahrscheinlich nicht erkennen wenn ich das jetzt hier kopiere
Clipboard
Translater will muss man das vielleicht erst kommt ist es gecrashed gerade was muss ich da jetzt machen um es zu
erst mal die git seiten ne tr ok ok tr ich habe ich habe schon aus dem crash gebracht
schon mal schon mal nice crashed
PIP 3 install ok ich muss erst mal Python install zeug jetzt hat es auch nicht copy pasted man
Also was muss ich was muss ich mal an extension
PIP 3 ich hab gar kein 30 Millionen PIP
Wie heißt denn das Package davon Python PIP ok
Jetzt sau ich mir das System noch ein bisschen weiter zu
Ist es jetzt installiert
U Launcher tr ach jetzt muss ich in api key eintippen ok Copy Copy vom Clipboard und wie benutze ich den Clipboard Manager
Copy Word C Copy vom Clipboard History
Ist eigentlich auch ganz ok muss ich sagen
Kommt man auch mit klar
Ich muss mich halt dran gewöhnen
C ok steinbar C und dann kannst du hier was suchen
Warum nicht ist auch ok kann man kann man benutzen
Was sagt denn Rohfi vs U Launcher was sagt denn Reddit dazu
Favorite Launcher Reddit was sagt Reddit interessiert mich wieder brennen was sagt Reddit dazu
Toller hintergrund Pippo Fett Time
Ist Borgia auch noch ein extra Launcher
Oder ist das irgendein Meme was ich nicht was ich nicht checke
Ach wegen Burger
Die schreibe ich hätte es auch für den Launcher gehalten mittlerweile weiß der Flow Launcher
Eigentlich sehr clever
Er hat einen Post gemacht über U Launcher und will eigentlich nur mit seinem Desktop flexen
Ist Albert nicht irgendein Mac OS Ding
Fast and Flexible Keyboard Launcher
A sophisticated Standalone Keyboard Launcher
Komm ich habe einen Snapshot ich kann alles installieren und dann wieder wieder runterhauen
Direkt weg genau
Jetzt erstmal C++ Kompilieren und dann direkt wieder Zack Falten wie dieses Terminal
Komplett zufrieden mit meinem neuen PC ja ich hatte noch nicht einen Crash das Ding ist wirklich super stable
Und schnell as fuck
Ich probiere komische Sachen für Linux aus die der Chat mir empfiehlt beziehungsweise mir um vom Becken drauf kommen
Burger
Ok redet es sich auch nicht so einig
Was zum Teufel ist Fuzzle warum gibt es tausend solcher Sachen alter
Können die nicht mal vielleicht fünf Ach das für wählen ok fünf machen das reicht und und dann ist gut
Ok es kompiliert noch mal gucken
Ja siehste das ist nur Single Threaded da war Rust aber Placingly Faster
Was sind die neuen Specs machen wir Ausrufezeichen PC viel zu teuer
Viel zu teuer
Ok während er kompiliert können wir es uns zusammen angucken und mir kann noch mal einer abgehen auf meinen neuen Rechner
Was für ein OS Type 64bit Linux das reicht
Also was haben wir hier drinne guck mal
2TB Achso ja gut das ist die SSD ich habe ja mittlerweile deutlich mehr SSDs drin ich habe meine alten SSD alle zusammen gesammelt und reingepappt
13900K 64G RAM 4090 RTX
Ein Mainboard
Ein Kontakt Frame für die Wasserkühlung ein fettes Gehäuse eine Wasserkühlung und ein ordentliches Netzteil
So siehts aus
Boah der kompiliert ja wieder das halbe Internet hier
So bin gerade neu bei der Rylai IDE sehr gute sehr gute Wahl
Ist das System Namespace standardmäßig importiert wenn man neue Projekte anlegt
Das hat mit Rylai nichts zu tun
Die Projekte die dort angelegt werden sind das was die.NET CLI anlegt
Und ja die normalen die die die Projekte die.NET CLI anlegt ist standardmäßig ein Hello World mit glaube ich 3-4 Imports drinne
Das hab ich nicht gemacht ja ich hab jetzt... Moment ist es abgebrochen?
Moment ist es beim...
Nee oder? Nee es hat es hat... ach nee hier unten war das ja
Ok wie heißt dieses Ding jetzt jetzt jetzt Albert ok
Sie sieht schon mal sieht schon mal richtig oh sieht schon mal richtig oldschool aus das Interface
Theme Spotlight Dark alles klar
Ok
Clip Search
Also das Ding durchsucht
Weder Clipboard noch noch
Und was anderes Files
Extensions
Es gibt Extensions und es gibt Plugins ok
Das alles
Ok Applications
Chrome interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
Ok es gibt schon mal keine Clipboard Integration so wie es aussieht
Ach nee Copy Snippets to the Clipboard Snippets heißt das ok
Kann man das jetzt ach hier Snippets
Nee Moment Nee Nee Nee
Ok es gibt tatsächlich keine Clipboard das ist aber auch schon sieht auch schon ziemlich oldschool aus
Ok probier mal aus zack achja hier Firefox
Nee das gefällt mir nicht das Ding
Weiß nicht aber das ist irgendwie
So ohne Clipboard
Clipboard History Feature
Gibt's nicht
Das ist natürlich blöd
Ja da ist ein Plugin
Das ist halt Leute Plugin Architekturen schön und gut
Das blöde ist nur dass dort halt die Maintainer öfters mal wegrennen bei den Plugins
Also ich finde so eine Anwendung muss schon eine gute gute Core Funktionalität mitbringen
Sonst
Ich werd bei Rofi bleiben
Rofi kannst du easy Sachen reinpipen
Ich weiß ich kanns immer Ulauncher einfach Sachen reinpipen so nach dem Motto Echo
Nee
Weil dann wäre das easy da könnte ich da könnte man da alles alles mit reinhauen
Leute ich weiß nicht also ich glaube ich glaube ich werde bei Rofi mit so einem Billig Billig Custom Theme bleiben und fertig
Ich meine ich bin ich bin echt
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht was ich da mehr von brauchen würde
Ich meine ich kann
Ich meine ich habe einen Clipboard Manager
Ich meine vielleicht werde ich die Farme ein bisschen anpassen und gut ist
So Clipboard Manager und ein Application Launcher fertig
Mehr benutze ich nicht vielleicht vielleicht ist noch Emojis
Ok wisst ihr wisst ihr was wir machen wir machen das ganz einfach
Wir machen das ganz einfach
Home Max Local Share Themes Slate
Ein viel steht ja da nicht drinnen wir reden hier um paar um paar Zeilen
Wo wo muss wo muss das hin
Home
Local Share Rofi Themes
Das Ding wieder weg yes Rofi
Kommt wieder Ruf und
Wo ist er
Sag
Gebe ihm
Genau
Rofi Show Die Menu
Was war es noch mal das will ich ja nicht einfügen
Les Ok Konfig Rofi Nee wo Gott Alter
Please
Local Share
Local
Share
Ach das gibt es da wieder nicht
Mk dir Local Share Mk dir Minus P
Local Share Rofi Themes war es glaube ich
Genau
Dann Slate Punkt Rasi
Zack Zack rein jetzt
Steam
Selektor
Das war es
Can't read Konfig ja mich nicht
Es ist schon funktioniert
Und jetzt kopieren wir noch das andere rüber
Ruf
Und dann ist gut
Wir müssen es ja nicht unbedingt
Kannst du nicht beschweren oder
Die Schrift ist anders
Ich brauche ich brauche nicht heck ich brauche heck
Mono glaube ich dass es stimmt
Und warum sieht das jetzt anders aus
Warum sieht das jetzt anders aus Sekunde Sekunde
Ja aber das sollte doch keinen großen Unterschied machen
Wobei das sieht nicht anders aus
Das sieht eigentlich
Ok Firefox haben wir mal beidem wir brauchen mal was zum vergleichen
Das ist eine andere font die ist die ist das ist eine andere font
Das sind die Spaces die Spaces sind anders
Das ist das ist das ist eine ganz andere font
Du hast es im West am umgestellt ja und
Also jetzt
Ich habe doch hier
Das ist eine andere font